you get this all the time but just take  the compliment you  are perhaps one of the most beautiful  women i've ever seen on the planet  that's  very sweet stop it i mean even in that  dress  oh my gosh like god damn it he had a  good day with you ma'am okay  so aisha how is your mommy i know you  have wine yes  so how is your mommy pandemic going is  remote learning the worst for you as  well  it's going right like it's going um  but luckily for me stefan has really  stepped in  um with the education and their  schooling yeah and i'm okay with that  because i said you know i birthed  them so now you can birth and nurture  their education  i get it so and he's actually doing it  he's doing it yeah i'm so grateful but  it's you know  he's making up for lost time to be quite  frank because he  would sleep through all of the diaper  changes in the late nights when they  were babies and so now this is his  strong suit  well it's all about being a good team so  that's awesome